hey I've got one of the funniest clips
ever about dr. ben Carson former
Republican nominee we've talked about
his strange personality and over the
weekend someone's that David did you see
that former Republican presidential
candidate ben Carson during an interview
in the middle of an interview realized
he forgot his luggage and he walked away
during the interview he had a panicked
look on his face and then just walked
away and I said there is no possible way
I'm sure it was a Saturday Night Live
sketch or something
but no it is all too real it happened he
was being interviewed in his old
neighborhood in Detroit there in support
of Trump when he suddenly remembered
something and I hope you're watching
along with me because there's a moment
when the CNN interviewer is still
talking during which you see a panicked
look on Ben Carson's face and it is
absolutely bizarre let's take a look at
it here one of my favorites mr. Trump
here I asked him how did it go and he
said great and he said he learns a lot
of things what do you think you took
away from from today okay looks like dr.
Carson is gonna try and find his luggage
and he'll be right back with us but this
is this is right here we're right in
front of the home of dr. ben Carson this
is just absolutely the best and he came
back to the interview I mean although he
genuinely just forgot where his luggage
was and realized something about that
question about Trump from the CNN
reporter reminded ben Carson that he had
no clue whatsoever where his luggage was
yeah I don't know what the commentary is
my commentary is mostly that Carson was
brought in to - again on this Detroit
pandering trip Trump going to a black
church and trying to dance but his feet
didn't move on the floor and that really
hinders your ability to look like you're
dancing like a normal person bringing in
ben Carson to do what I don't know I
guess just talk about how great Trump is
he spoke to the press following a brief
tour of his childhood home the old I
forgot my luggage line well played dr.
Carson was my original thought but he
did come back to the interview did he
actually come back I have a surprise
you'd like run to the airport and get on
a plane and fly to another country
because maybe maybe some part of him
actually realized that he's supporting
someone who does
support his own identity I do wonder
whether Trump or whether Carson rather
is sort of like I don't really want to
be doing this at all but I don't think
he's in a position where he feels
obligated and unless he thinks it's it's
about a possible position in the Trump
administration which Trump has already
alluded to maybe giving ben Carson I
don't know that that's the motivation
Trump's a disaster obviously but we
really dodged a bullet with dr. ben
Carson Gamefly is sort of like Netflix
for video games they have over 8,000 new
and classic games for xbox one Xbox 360
ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low used price
there's never any due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a free 30-day
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free
30-day trial for the David Pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s